Brandon important victory for you but it
wasn't easy and this uh specific moment
you spent a lot of time on B5 here it's
also blitzing out his moves what was
your assessment at this point can we
start off by saying how ridiculous 28 he
is or whatever it is yeah I mean he
obviously deserves to be here he's
playing chess like he's proving himself
and there are no easy games in the
tournament absolutely not and yeah I
mean he fought super well the entire
game it was probably up until even the
last moment but I felt like I was trying
to get to that okay okay I don't want to
know what the computer says but we'll
get to but yeah okay so in this position
yeah so
I figured a new Knight B6 was not the
correct move I mean I knew this whole G6
I basically felt a little loose because
Knight's stone age five right normally
they only back to F6 first
um it only really makes sense of
blocking it but the thing is if I spend
like a logical like waiting room Knight
D2 let's say
once you get some Bishop E6 it feels
like he should be doing pretty much okay
here you can rebound
995 I think is a bigger issue
um and in general yeah white should be
slightly better I can instead of I can
collect Queen B3 or something to cover
the C4 square but it didn't feel like
anything special here and I figured I'd
probably have something better so I
started looking at B5 now the New Black
would like to play as cb5
um and if I take back then A5 is pretty
comfortable for black and mink so
instead I have this A5 move here and so
I spent a lot of time calculating this
because so black can try B4 or Knight D7
and the issue is let's say black goes 97
after A5 sure
um it looks like black might be in time
after Knight takes C5 Queen B6 E4 and B6
here and if black is one more Bishop B7
is fine but I have E5 here which is
pretty important I think it's pretty
serious trouble yeah yeah and if instead
of B6 black like wasting their movements
I don't like repeat
let's say then I'm in time for Rook C1
and again stopping B5 B6 to The Rook C6
so
yeah this is nice so yeah black can't
really get developed here's the issue
and then instead of um after CBA 5 black
tries B4 here
um
net A2
so 9c4 is the only way that makes sense
and queen dicks before
he's got a trade take take Bishop E6 and
now I think the issue in the end is I
was trying to figure out the right move
order E4 is playable
so I can take on C4 I think DC4 and
Knight D2 and now so I'm wearing 94 and
Knight C5 and the flat plays something
like Knight F6 then I'm just inside for
Knight B1 and I think black's in pretty
serious trouble here yeah that's nice so
you're calculating this is crazy the
thing is like I have to be careful let's
say instead of like Knight D2 I'm gonna
start with D5 for example
um Bishop D7 Knight D2 black and try
like Rick fc8
um and the issue now is if I go like
well 94 for example yeah then he's in
time for C3 and Rook C4 is a threat so
so there are a bunch of little tricks
like this I have to watch out for you
yes so I'm just calculating this on like
B5 and two intuitively felt like the way
to punish and it's always played but
yeah I wasn't I I need to make sure all
the lines worked out for me so he played
a b and C5 which I think was a good
practical Choice best move by the Angela
yeah the way yeah yeah surprisingly
difficult to figure out what to do here
I mean I I tried Queen A3 I actually
completely underestimated Bishop he's
like I mean I saw it but I thought like
I can put Queen dick C5 I just
completely forgot like in the end his
Knight will just come collect my b-pawn
yeah I thought I'd have an extra Pawn in
that game yeah
um so I tried yeah Queen A7 and okay in
general White's always slightly better
here but like to actually win this game
is another story very limited material
for sure yeah yeah I thought this queen
when it might have been clever to try to
get the C file um if he doesn't go for
an ig4 yeah but he went for this really
interesting Knight G4 brick C which I
didn't even consider for black
um and it feels strategically risky to
trade off the Knight but he's kind of
just in time to
yeah I thought he would keep the bishop
on C8 instead of Bishop D7
to me a public Bishop D7 was kind of a
step in the wrong direction I thought
you would go Bishop C8 Bishop C8 yeah
and try to just go King faking E7 pretty
quickly
um now he does have to watch out for
like an eventual
yeah not easy yeah I mean eventually
just have to watch out for some like
Rick H1 at some point with my Kingsland
G3 let's say yeah but if he places those
pieces correctly he probably yeah so
King 7 is already a blunder but if he
puts like to work on C5 at the right
moment I think maybe he'll have enough
characters and beep on like maybe Works
C5 here you know maybe F's this is
Still Remains complex I think but I
think what he got in the game
practically was pretty difficult with
his King kind of boxed out it was but
then it was this moment when
you got this point yeah yeah so I was
getting one time here and the thing is
after F4 by the way after F4 I think
even easier for black is to go F5 here
yeah I noticed that yeah I noticed in
the game I figure it was worth a shot
because I didn't really know what else
to try
um because I think it's by don't go F4
the issue is Blackstone she was worried
about this yeah there's something I have
to reacting even I can go B6 in some
moment too
um and like like it's not an immediate
draw it's not as easy as engine might
suggest anything right right but if you
take I take on F5 yeah or like I can
start with B6 here all right he wants to
just like give up the piece like this
yeah yeah I guess this is but even like
I can start with B6 after
um I can only GF and P6 after F5
yes uh is that an F3 I can I can take on
um or taking on an F5 first yeah and
then B6 maybe yeah and okay I mean I
guess that's a draw but like at least
once the game goes on yeah not easy not
easy but the thing is if I don't go F4
though like he's gonna go king of seven
next and I'm gonna get a similar kind of
working I can go B6 but I don't know
what I do against kf7 like obviously I'm
better here but I wasn't exactly sure I
guess I can play Slowly Rook A5 yeah
just some slow slow yeah it's probably
smarter I thought also because he was
starting to get low in time a move what
was it like 38 or something I no not
easy not easy yeah I know this gf4
should draw instead of Bishops he's like
yeah yeah and the issue is yeah if I go
King takes you give me a bishop C6 maybe
but okay let's say peace yeah if I think
takes then this is a dry out
yeah and so I can't do this because CD
King seven so instead I go over it takes
D7 here
and then I think it was yeah King E8
takes for C exactly yeah that's so if he
takes to the pawn you go to E8 if you if
you take with the King yeah it goes
exactly yeah so the things I noticed
that you should like I I noticed I
should have started with gf4 during the
game I'm just kind of hoping he wouldn't
play it especially because it would
force me to make a decision on which is
like trickier for him on move 40 yeah so
I was pretty glad this is like even if I
wasn't exactly sure that what he did
lose but like I don't know it was like
I kind of felt like I um
I at least avoided the danger because
now I have 30 minutes to to think and
you know figure out what at least the
best practical try would be Brandon
never easy to win a game but the result
is what counts how do you feel about
your shape so far are you getting warmed
up yeah I mean in general I think like
my play as sort of I wouldn't say it's
gotten better but I think I've
stabilized it but I've kind of you know
found my footing because especially
because like the last game was nice
basically a rest day
um and I was able to kind of reset in
this game like during the game it felt
like it was not great but okay seeing
now that I didn't really have any
chances I feel a bit better about this
game
um but I think it's still pretty early
in the tournament to make any
conclusions so just trying to take it
one game one game at a time and do the
best they can absolutely congratulations
guys any questions our congratulations
as well Brandon very nicely done and
that's what it takes sometimes